alister jones professeur politiques
associés de politique pardon à
l'université de montfort de leicester
bonsoir c'est notre rubrique donc vu de
l'extérieur tout d'abord et voilà
bonsoir alistair jaws merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir les
chiffres qu'on vient de voir sont quand
même assez inquiétant dont viennent
selon vous ces théories du complot nous
verrons
ils viennent de partout il des choses
les plus intéressantes c'est la
circulation dans les réseaux sociaux
toutes les histoires sont partis ils
peuvent être présentées comme étant du
pur fait et lorsqu'on voit les détails
de cette recherche
ils ont étudié ou les personnes
obtenaient leur information ce qui est
intéressant c'est le manque de confiance
envers les gouvernements et
l'information qu'il propage et envers
les autres sources ce traditionnel
d'information
c'est l'information véhiculée par un
automne à 30 cette idée des fake minus
des médias qui essayent de tromper les
gens de cacher la vérité
et oui lorsque ce georges histoire
commence à circuler alors elles prennent
de l'ampleur
les chercheurs de cette étude ont
découvert que 59% que d'après ces
personnes 59 % des gens pensent que les
autorités essaient de tromper les gens
mais les sondages pourrait être encore
plus important c'est le niveau de
méfiance envers le gouvernement
voici donc pourquoi ces versions
alternatives de la réalité apparaissent
alors on peut être anti système on peut
ne pas faire confiance aux autorités au
gouvernement
mais là les chiffres qu'on vient de voir
pardonnez moi mais ça confinent au
racisme et l'antisémitisme
les gens sont crédules à ce point là où
il ya un fond tout simplement de racisme
et d'antisémitisme
je pense que c'est un mélange des deux
lorsqu'on regarde les personnes
impliquées et les personnes qui sont le
plus susceptibles de croire à ces
théories du complot effectivement ce
sont des extrémistes de la gauche ou de
la droite et dans ces zones
effectivement on trouve plus de racisme
et d'antisémitisme
au centre il ya des personnes qui ont eu
tendance à être plus stable donc
effectivement il ya du racisme et
l'antisémisme ici en étudie les origines
option sur la question des origines du
court un navire russe 20 % des personnes
interrogées pensaient qu'il s'agissait
d'un complot et chinois arabe ou juif
donc ces histoires sont propagées dans
les réseaux sociaux qui est en fait une
chambre d'écho chambre de résonance donc
il écoute les personnes qu'ils sont
issus cible de croire et répète ce
informations à des personnes qui sont
également susceptibles de le croire et
donc c'est l'information tourne dans des
réseaux très serré effectivement là-bas
on trouve du racisme et l'antisémitisme
à leicester jones justement c'est
intéressant de savoir qui propagent ces
nouvelles est ce que ce sont justement
des gens qui cherchaient manipuler
l'opinion ou se sont simplement de
simples citoyens voilà qu'ils sont des
fakes news justement vous l'avez très
bien expliquée par avec des opinions
racistes antisémites et qui ont tout
simplement envie de propager de laine
sur les réseaux sociaux
le source
la source puis se trouver n'importe où
si vous allez sur facebook ou twitter et
que quelqu'un peut bien message
dix ans à telle personne est morte le
message et retweeter ou partager la
personne n'aurait pu mourir il ya cinq
ou dix ans mais l'histoire est présentée
comme étant une nouvelle donc certaines
personnes propagent ces histoires en
pensant de bonne foi quelle qu'elles
sont vraies cela peut être dû augmente
d'éducation de son site de conscience
sociale autant avoir un degré
d'innocence ou en tout cas de naïveté
parmi certaines de ces personnes mais il
ya également des éléments marginaux qui
propagent volontairement ces histoires
et eux seul et fut profondément des
réseaux traditionnels de ce que toute
notre homme qualifie de cette news donc
quelle que soit l'information véhiculée
par les réseaux les informations
traditionnelles ils pensent le contraire
donc quelles que soient les preuves
qu'on leur présente ces personnes vont
refuser d'être persuadé ils vont
continuer à faire véhiculer ce qu'ils
pensent être des faits et donc ces
marginaux sont de plus en plus
mainstream
de nombreuses rumeurs ont été présentés
lundi dans les médias que le coronavirus
était liée à l'installation des réseaux
5g et d'emma 5g ont été détruits parce
que des gens pensaient que c'était
l'origine du coronavirus donc il y a des
naïfs mais il ya également des marchés
nous et on le comprend bien merci à
lyster jones professeur associé de
politique à l'université de montfort de
leicester d'avoir à essayer et d en tout
cas à comprendre ces théories de complot